if you'd like to chat with me make sure
that your nickname and Discord in the
waiting area is your name
and your location very very important
like for example Harris from Atlanta is
going to be invited to be next on today
Harris from Atlanta welcome to the
program
hey David
how are you
good how are you I'm doing well um so my
question is how do you think that people
are able to rationalize in their heads
when they hear either a pundit or a
politician say directly contradicting
things often in the same speech or
broadcast or debate or whatever
what what do you mean
so the the two examples I kind of have
uh number one is with the Trump
documents where at the same time they
were planted by the FBI to catch Trump
and that we need to investigate that but
also Trump Declassified the documents
right uh as as president oh yeah yeah
yeah so at the same time and expected to
both be true but they can't both be true
yeah this is um this is a sort of throw
a bunch of crap at the wall and see what
sticks we see there are so many other
good examples of this another one from
the right is they say
um we've got to stop all these lazy
immigrants from coming in and collecting
welfare and they are taking our jobs
with oh wait a second are they not
working or are they working so much that
there aren't jobs left for Americans
which of the two things is it or another
example was the January 6th the January
6th attendees were both completely peace
full and it was actually antifa being
violent like wait a second so were they
peaceful or was it antifa being violent
which are the two things was it yeah I
don't think it matters anymore because
right-wing voters haven't cared about
hypocrisy and conflicts and double
standards for a very long time so I just
I just don't I do not think they care at
all
yeah that I I would definitely agree
that is probably the case like I think
it's really that simple
I so I think the the first time like
obviously it's been going on for a long
time this isn't a new issue but like the
first time where I like fully noticed it
within a span where two statements were
set in this band about five seconds of
each other whereas in the debate between
Trump and Biden where they were talking
about Trump's taxes and he says at this
in the same statement that he pays
millions and millions in taxes but also
the reason he was able to pay so little
in taxes because of Biden's the tax laws
no it's it's insane it's completely nuts
so yeah I mean listen they're going to
keep doing it until there's consequences
to doing it and right now their voters
don't care so they'll keep doing it
yeah probably
all right my friend thank you there's
Harris from Atlanta
all right there goes Harris very very
powerful stuff
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below